jeandel flaysakier vous une histoire de
gonfler parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé je
parlais pas de vous on a beaucoup parlé
pendant la girouette tous les gens qui
prenaient des anabolisants il y en a
beaucoup parlé de ce qui promet d'autres
trucs et maintenant parle des vaches des
veaux des cochons qui prennent la même
chose c'est bien qu'il y ait rouyère une
affaire éclate avec des des boeufs
qu'ont adoptée avec un produit qui en
théorie sert à soigner les bronchites
des chevaux mais vous c'est qui encore
plus fou vous savez que un cinquième de
la production mondiale d antibiotiques
passe dans la nourriture quotidienne des
animaux en cinquième un cinquième 20 %
de ce qu'on produit dans le monde en
antibiotiques ne sert pas à traiter les
gens mais à nourrir les animaux parce
que ça serve de là on appelle cela
pudiquement des promoteurs de croissance
et à grossir c'est ça parce qu'ils sont
moins malades ils ont moins de fièvre et
quand ils ont de la fièvre
quand on a de la fièvre nous ont détruit
nos protéines à cause de deux plein de
phénomènes bizarres mais les animaux
c'est pareil les protéines c'est la
viande donc pour empêcher que de
détruire cette viande est bon on leur
donne des antibiotiques mais c'est
génial dans comprend un steak et puis en
prenant de la pénicilline en même temps
un peu près oui pierre je vais vous
narrer une histoire rapidement et
d'amérique est un exemple de cette
réussite
il ya quelques années aux états unis
dans trois étapes très éloignés les uns
des autres l'orégon l'illinois et puis
un autre qui était sur la côte est ce
vraiment des mille îles a toujours été
la catégorie d une amie emma prend aulas
et la wii plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres une vingtaine de personnes
qui ont été hospitalisées ont été
hospitalisés pour des affaires de gastro
entérite des troubles digestifs et puis
on comprenait pas pourquoi n'arrivait
pas à les guérir malgré des
antibiotiques et là on a isolé une
bactérie qu'on appelle une salmonelle
mais très bizarre les superflics médecin
d'atlanta en bas aux états unis vous me
suivez l'attendait pas
voilà ils sont quatre ils sont allés
faire une enquête parce que justement
des données cette bactérie soit
interrogé les gens est le point commun
entre ces personnes c'est qu'elle avait
tout consommer des hamburgers alors on
s'est dit est ce que c'est le pain ce
que c'est les oignons est ce que c'est
les légumes la moutarde le ketchup
on a tout fait et puis on s'est rendu
compte en fait que le seul point commun
c'est que toute la viande qui avait
servi dans ces trois états venait du
même élevage dans le sud des côtes à
lahoud sourire à une nord dakota juste
en dessous de ces quotas
et ils sont allés voir le troupeau et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont constaté dans le
troupeau que dans l'intestin de ces
animaux il y avait la même bactérie et
ses animaux manger tous les jours en
plus de l'herbe et différentes choses
manger du chloramphénicol un
antibiotique à battre
alors vous savez on était spectateur un
terme généralement vous remercie de me
dire qu'en europe en europe tout ça
c'est quasiment interdit que l'europe
est beaucoup plus prudente que les états
unis et que ça se produit pas beaucoup
ils n'arrivent pas français ça n'arrive
non c'est vrai que ça n'arrive pas en
france parce qu'on est dans l'europe et
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser tous
ces produits bien le tout c'est de le
faire savoir le faire savoir c'est la
publicité la publicité c'est bernheim
bernay et sur ce plateau réduction pitt
j'aimerais bien que l'on ait la guerre
entre 1,6 km
[Musique]